our Lord and Savior
excellent the American flag baseball's
my favorite sport here at sport Diesel's
my favorite sport also known as the
Stars and Stripes our Lord
and Savior excellent now for something
new this is a national holiday called
Thanksgiving on the fourth Thursday of
every November families feast and think
about what they're thankful for which
ones said daddy do I have a daddy of
course you do
dr. Vogel balm filling does that mean
you're my mommy sure I can be your mommy
so you love me
I do
and you'll always take care of me always
it's okay we'll take care of her just
like the others today we had another
incident but this time the subject was
not driven by anger but by something
else altogether
I told dr. Vogel Baum that the subject
was obviously suffering from isolation
adduce depression but he didn't respond
he just told me to find another tutor
while we didn't tell you
I'm your father
we
our family
hey everybody it's Charlie hopefully you
guys have had a chance to see the boys
I've gotten a lot of requests to do more
videos for it they've officially started
production on season 2 so they're
releasing these early promos just
getting people hyped up the producers
have already been talking about it doing
interviews they say that Amazon just
gave them an extra dump truck of money
they're using a lot of that extra money
to add extra characters make extra big
action scenes so the first episode of
season 2 which they just finished
shooting is gonna be way way crazier
than the stuff that you saw during
season 1 if you're brand new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos given that people like season
1 so much I'll probably wind up doing
more videos for season 2 episodes the
promo was all about this really sinister
moment of them conditioning homelander
as a child in the most way
possible there's nothing that seems good
about this scene who could have guessed
things would have gone completely off
the rails with him but here's my top 10
predictions for season 2 just based on
the stuff that they set up at the end of
the series hanging plot threads and some
stuff that they've already changed from
the comics in what the producers have
said so number 10 what's gonna happen
between butcher homelander butcher's
wife who's been missing for the last
eight years and homelander son the new
Superboy of the series the writers
really wanted you to think that a lot of
homelander's problems in his actions are
the result of the terrible upbringing in
desire to have a family now that he
thinks he has a shot at that through his
son like he's completely smitten with
the idea of being a father to this boy
the promise of the teaser and the
reversal is probably that things seem
like they're gonna be okay for a little
while home Lander seems like he wants to
settle down reform and be a good father
to this boy be the good father that he
never had but then because he is who he
is he just continues to get more and
more out of control on his path to
eventually the White House because
season 1 was all about dealing with the
military they're gonna get into that
during season 2 the next step beyond
that is getting into the government and
that means the White House so 9 what is
Butcher going to do about homelander son
and his wife who technically he's still
married to they didn't get a divorce
when she took off eight years ago I
still think hundred-percent he's gonna
try and use homelander son against him
because before this he said that
homelander's weakness was Stillwell and
now the only thing that homelander
about is his son so his son is his new
weakness eight what's gonna happen now
that they're letting the military use
superheroes and what about all the
compound V villains that homelander was
artificially creating in cells
all over the world
general Arc of most series like this is
that the real villains kind of eat
themselves alive through internal
conflicts undoing themselves after they
go totally off the rails in a very
public way
butchers whole mission is either to get
homelander to stand trial or at least
get the public to realize how terrible a
person he is so I think he's gonna try
and take advantage of homelander going
continually off the rails and push him
into a situation where he reveals his
true self to the public seven what about
the female of the species she's supposed
to be one of the most powerful
characters on the series next to Queen
Maeve and homelander Frenchie's helping
bring her humanity out that's just gonna
continue she's meant to be sort of a
juxtaposition with homelander urge showing
you that yes super heroes who are
animals can be really good people like
they're turning her from an animal into
a normal person while homelander is a
nice person seemingly turning into an
animal six what's going on with
starlight and Hughie now so it seems
like they're in a full-blown
relationship going into season two and
she's gonna continue to inform for the
boys maybe also try to turn Queen Maeve
because she clearly hates what's going
on with the seven she doesn't like
homelander but everyone is terrified
of him so that's why you haven't seen
her go against him in a really physical
way yet just because she knows that she
couldn't win against him in a one-on-one
fight five what's gonna happen to the
deep they kind of kicked him out of the
seven like they basically told him they
were benching him at the end of the
season which is why he was so pissed off
but the joke of the series is is that
most of the time when they need to save
someone and they need a super hero
it doesn't involve water so his powers
for the most part are virtually useless
and a lot of the things that they do
that was why they developed him as that
social media star and always used him
for that stuff like oh here you know you
can go do this and be the PR person
while we have these other super heroes
saving people he's one of those
characters who's trying to reform so
fifty-fifty he also turns and helps out
the boys with Queen Maeve and Starlight
eventually for what are they going to do
to clean up the mess from the end of the
season so they blew up Stilwell's house
she was already dead because homelander had killed her and I'm pretty sure
that homelander did not save her baby
so they blew that baby up too a lot of
people wondering about why they didn't
focus on that they just meant to show
you how little homelander actually
cares about people like he was only
focused on going to meet his son in
showing butcher are shoving it in his
face three like I said they're gonna do
the hero gasm eventually but might not
happen till season three in the comics
what they use that for was it was
butchers team of the boys infiltrating a
hero gasm to learn more about bots
secret long-term plans to try and
infiltrate the white house short term
right now is heroes infiltrating the
military next step is the White House in
the government - what's going on with
black noir and have they changed him
significantly from the comics because
the female of the species was able to
cut him but she's supposed to be super
powerful - so it is possible that she
could cut him but a lot of people are
thinking and I'm thinking it's correct
that they've changed who he is from the
comic book version of the character it's
meant to be this big twist that you
don't find out about till really later
and I think that they've swerved on that
in favor of what's going on with home
Lander in his son this new super boy
because the comic book version of this
kind of moment here was very very
different what happened is is that
butcher's wife really did die but she
died giving birth to the baby in their
room it just grew superfast killed her
during the birth then butcher killed the
baby and that was the end of it so with
this moment here were completely in new
territory from the comic book and I
think they'll use a lot of this in the
way they end the series in whatever last
season they wind up doing but number one
how many more seasons are they going to
give it right now expectation is four to
five seasons with the amount of money
they're spending seth rogen actually
joked the amount of money they're
spending they have to renew us so that
they can make their money back really
happy with what they did with season one
it was a great parody of the Justice
League and the DC characters obviously
homelander being like the darkest
timeline in Justice version of Superman
that you want to think about probably
even darker than in Justice Superman but
the TV show pulls way back on how
graphic the comic book gets I'm only
expecting eight episodes from season two
there's not that much comic book
material for them to go on they could
expand on a lot of moments which is
probably what they'll have to do in
later seasons but it sounds like it's
gonna be awesome so just post all your
theories about season 2 in the
comments and let me know if you want me
to do more videos for the boys there's a
couple of their big videos that I'm
working on why you guys wait for me to
post that click here for my boys
season 1 video and click here for my
Black Panther 2 teaser video thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome see you guys tonight!